muy bien amigos míos ya ha pasado un
tiempo desde la última vez que les tuvo
información acerca de ver si del ebook o
de cualquier otro juego pero nuevamente
llegó la hora pues a pesar de que
residen y volví les fue éste nada se
solamente un par de meses ya tenemos
rumores acerca de los demás juegos de la
saga y qué montón de rumores pues
tenemos información de reciente y un
nuevo resident evil revelations 3 y del
remake de res de antiguo 4 así que
prepara las nalgas porque la información
es bastante
[Música]
ya en vídeos anteriores les ha traído
información filtrada de otros juegos de
'resident evil' y de igual manera que
con esos vídeos tengo que hacer un par
declaraciones antes de comenzar primero
todo lo que te voy a contar en este
vídeo son de momento rumores pues aún no
hay nada confirmado pero la información
viene de ins aires ya muy conocidos
personas que son muy reconocidas por la
veracidad de su información hace que
todo esto es muy confiable pero no dejan
de ser rumores así que tomarlo con calma
tranquilo viejo y segundo si no es
jugador resentido village tu tranquilo
este vídeo no contiene ni un solo
spoiler acerca de la historia del juego
así que míralo con calma crack
comencemos por resident evil 9 o así ya
tenemos un poco de información acerca
del juego yo sé los cabrones trabajan
rápido vamos a hablar primero de este
juego pues es irónicamente decir que más
información tenemos como dije bills se
estrenó hace muy poco pero los últimos
meses el conocido en sádr dos goles nos
dio conocer un par de cosas interesantes
acerca del noveno título de la saga en
primer lugar nos reveló que capcom ha
estado trabajando en resident y 29 desde
antes de que salir a recetar y bebido
leche es decir estaban desarrollando los
dos juegos al mismo tiempo pero además
también os digo que este noveno juego
sería el que tendría el mayor tiempo de
desarrollo en toda la saga usualmente
los juegos de realidad y gusto van
aproximadamente entre 3 a 4 años para
ser creados en su totalidad pero segundo
gol en el juego está un desarrollo desde
el 2018 y planea ser estrenado alrededor
del año 2000 4 o 2025 lo que sería en un
promedio de entre 6 a 7 años de
desarrollo convirtiéndolo en el juego
con el mayor tiempo de desarrollo en
toda la saga esto si lo pensamos no es
tan descabellado pues con bill es ya
estrenado capcom de momento quiere
centrarse en otros juegos mientras le da
más tiempo en el horno a resident tipos
9 pero esto no es todo lo que se nos
reveló acerca de este juego pues es una
información revelada
resident y voz 9 cerraría la trilogía de
en winter's que comenzó con resident y
bosh 7 pues ellos saben que a pesar de
que la historia de it and see' está bien
debe tener un cierre bastante pronto por
lo que el futuro 'resident evil' 9 le
dará una conclusión final a la historia
de italo lo que además hace que esta
imagen sea más curiosa pues todo indica
a que esta imagen es un arte conceptual
de rosmery winter's la hija de tan pero
ya siendo adulta y cargando una escopeta
rompe madres
esto son muchas personas podría indicar
que ella será la protagonista del
siguiente juego o que aparecerá de
alguna manera pero la verdad no se sabe
nada con certeza así que de momento lo
único que tenemos que es esta imagen
ahora recientemente en el discordias
harlem nos reveló que jill valentine
hará una aparición y será un personaje
muy importante en la trama de algún
juego aunque no está 100% seguro de si
saldrá en recibos 9 o recién tivo y
revelations 3 si nos asegura que estará
presente en algunos de estos dos juegos
y ya como último trocito de información
que se ha revelado de este juego se nos
dijo que resentir 19 sería de momento el
último juego numerado de la saga por lo
que por lo menos por ahora capcom no
tiene planes de hacer ni 'resident evil'
10 ni 11 ellos estarían más centrados en
entregas aparte o spin off de la saga
como revelations o algo por el estilo
pues quieren darle un respiro a la saga
principal esto por ahora a la fecha que
estoy realizando este vídeo es toda la
información que tenemos acerca de
errores en 29 pero de igual manera
tenemos un montón de tiempo pues como
dije resident y vos 9 a la venta entre
2024 y 2025 así que aún tenemos un par
de años para ahorrar
muy bien ahora sigamos con resident evil
revelations 3 como ya muchos deben saber
al comienzo del desarrollo de 'resident
evil' es originalmente se tenía planeado
que este juego fuera en realidad
revelations 3 pero la mitad del camino
serón cuenta del potencial que tenía el
juego y decidieron hacerle una entrega
en numerada de la saga pero esto no
quiere decir que hayan abandonado la
idea de un posible revelations 3 de
hecho es todo lo contrario pues ya
tenemos piezas de capcom ya estaría
desarrollando el juego a lo largo de
estos últimos meses muchísimos rumores
han estado rondando en internet uno de
sus rumores dice que el juego no se
llamaría revelations 3 como tal sino que
tendría un título original y pasaría a
llamarse resident ebook outbreak que no
se comiera significa pero de igual
manera según estos rumores el juego
sería exclusivo temporal para nintendo
suites pero que eventualmente saldría
para las demás plataformas y sería
estrenado el próximo año en el 2022 de
la trama tenemos muy pocos detalles se
dice que será protagonizada por rebecca
chambers que hace tiempo que no aparecía
en ninguno de los juegos principales y
también tendríamos partes del juego en
donde poder jugar como león y siguiendo
a estos dos personajes tendremos que
descubrir la verdad sobre un nuevo virus
que amenaza con acabar cientos de vidas
originalmente este juego se suponía que
debía ser estrenado en 2021 pero debido
al cómic es muy probable que sea
estrenado a inicios del 2022 muchas
otras fuentes también aseguran que en el
2020 de manera secreta se exhibió una
demo jugable de este juego bajo el
nombre clave investigation según estas
personas esta demo toma lugar en una
universidad llena de estudiantes
infectados en donde se ve que tendría
que abrirse paso por los pasillos para
tratar de descubrir que estaba pasando
esta demo se dice que era muy parecida a
la del remake de resident y bulldog con
bastantes puzzles y bastante espacio
para explorar pero la demo acababa
súbitamente cuando lográbamos entrar en
la oficina principal de la universidad
en donde de la nada un personaje
misterioso le dan su madre a rebeca y la
nokia
siendo ese el final de la demo jugable
lastimosamente eso es todo lo que
sabemos por ahora del juego pero muchos
de estos 'insiders' aseguran que en
septiembre el juego será anunciado de
manera oficial y podremos saber más
sobre este misterioso respectivo
outbreak así que sólo tenemos que
esperar un poco más
[Música]
finalmente hay que hablar del remake de
resident evil 4 ver que lastimosamente
es del que menos información tenemos
antes de que se emocionen no el juego no
está ni cerca de ser estrenado por ahora
las personas en capcom están más
centradas en resident evil out rachel de
él se divide y en la versión de resident
evil 4 para realidad virtual por lo que
según fuentes confiables se espera que
este juego sea estrenado a mediados de
2023 o 2024 justo antes de 'resident
evil' 9 el juego lleva en desarrollo
poco tiempo pero se sabe que el proyecto
se conoce con el nombre clave motosierra
y que hace más o menos medio año el
proyecto fue reiniciado desde cero
debido a diferencias creativas pues no
les gustaba el rumbo que el juego estaba
tomando en ese momento así que
decidieron reiniciar el proyecto para
tomar un camino distinto ellos quieren
que el remake sea fiel al juego original
pero también quieren agregarle un par de
cositas extra como ya lo hicieron con
los remakes de recibos 2 y 3 además de
esto se dice que albert wesker hará una
aparición en este juego y que capcom
quiere hacer que este remake mucho más
grande y largo que el juego original
expandiendo una historia con los
personajes tal vez agregando personajes
nuevos o que no se vieron en el juego
original y en general dándole un montón
de contenido adicional al juego por lo
que podemos esperar un juego muy fiel al
reciente hubo 4 original pero con
muchísimo más contenido
es una pena pero de momento esa es toda
la información que puedo ofrecerte
acerca de estos tres juegos pero estoy
seguro que conforme pase el tiempo poco
a poco vamos a ir sabiendo más acerca de
los siguientes juegos de recibo así que
mantente al pendiente pues si se sabe
algo importante aquí te lo informaría
por ahora el calendario para capcom
queda de la siguiente manera 'resident
evil' out wait para el 2022 resident
evil 4 remake para 2023 o 2024 y
finalmente resident y 19 para 2025 nada
más como dije al principio a pesar de
que toda la información que acabas de
oír proviene de fuentes bastante
confiables no dejan de ser rumores y no
se sabrá con certeza algo hasta que se
comunique de manera oficial así que
tómate todo esto con mucha calma pero
hay aquí entre nos todo se ve de [ __ ]
madre tú con quien todo esto la verdad
que se oye genial y muy prometedor pero
dime tú qué te parecen todos estos
rumores acerca de la saga de resident y
butt antes de irme no te olvides de
seguirme en twitter y ver mis otros
vídeos
ahora si me voy hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]